[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
Guys, today we're here
with my new friend Matt,
who's going to be showing
us some of the steps
in how to make some
bezel set infinity rings.
[Music]
Some of you may have seen a while
back Grant's story on Instagram
where he came and
he made a ring here at this shop,
and he thought it was so cool that
we're going to make a few more,
and what he really wanted to do
was make sort of an Infinity Gauntlet.
But rather than a gauntlet,
just make a different
ring for each finger,
and so we've got a whole bunch of stones,
and Matt is going to show us how
to take the rest of the raw materials,
and put everything together
to turn them into rings.
>> Okay. So the first thing
we're going to do
is we're going to working
with this red stone first.
This is the pinky stone for Grant.
We are going to be grinding the
back down and making it a bit flatter
so it's going to sit inside
of the setting a bit better.
So first, we're going to [inaudible]
with the lapidary machine.
What it does is it spins really really fast,
sand paper that keeps wet,
and we're going to grind down the back.
>> Interesting. Thing is
grinding down the stone.
It's really flattening it out.
But it's not something that's like really
wearing away at my fingers,
which means it has
very very hard grinding
but it's such a low grip that it's
not really doing anything to my skin.
[Music]
Now, I've got this stone
ground down on the back.
What's the next step?
>> Okay. So now what we're going
to be doing is getting the bezel.
So we're going to be using this
thin brass sheet as our bezel,
and we're going to wrap it around
the stone as tightly as we can,
and figure out exactly how long
this brass wire needs to be
to hug that stone just perfectly.
So now, go ahead and
use these flush cutters
to cut just a little bit extra.
and make sure you're
cutting at a 90 degree angle.
[Music]
>> All right, we've got our little band
cut in pretty exactly
sized around the stone.
What do we do?
>> Okay so, we always double check it,
and make sure that
it really does hug it
and it looks like it's perfect.
So now what we want to do
is we want to make sure
that these ends are flat.
When you cut metal,
rarely does it ever cut clean.
It usually pinches it off at the tip.
So we're gonna use a file
to file down those tips
to make it more flat.
>> Got it.
>> And when we're filing, we want
to keep that at a perfect angle.
So we're not filing any--
anything off that.
>> You don't lose any distance.
>> Okay. So this is where
it gets a lot more fun.
We are going to solder
these ends together.
So the first step is going to be
making them what we call kissing.
So you want to get
them right matched up.
So what I usually do is I go over,
and I go under to create
some springiness to it,
and then I try and get them
matched up just right
so I'll have you work on that.
>> Cool.
>> We have our two ends
matched up perfectly.
And now we're going to use
this thing called third arm,
which is just some tweezers that
are held out of this platform.
>> It's like reverse tweezers.
>> Exactly.
And it's going to hold these in place
and then we're going to apply flux.
And what flux does is as it heats up,
it cleans the surface of the brass,
and tells the solder where to go basically.
Without flux, the solder
would just ball up,
and it wouldn't melt into the crack.
It will just end up overheating,
and it potentially could
end up damaging the brass.
So we add flux every time
we do any soldering.
Solder comes in three different heats.
We have hard medium and easy,
and it's basically all that is
is that it is a solder
that is mixed with different
amounts of alloys.
So the less alloys there are,
the hotter it needs to be the melt.
The more alloys there are,
the less heat we need to make it melt.
This is 0.925 sterling silver,
but what it is it's mixed with
I think zinc and tin,
and zinc and tin are metals that
melt at a much lower temperatures.
So, we're gonna start
working out with hard solder,
then work our way down to easy.
[Music]
>> We took our soldering bar
and we just laid it right across the gap
which is currently closed together nicely.
Having the flux on there also helps
just keep that right where we put it.
It's obviously not rolling off
because the flex is kind of a goo.
So I'm gonna take this torch,
and start kind of far away,
let it heat up,
be moving in closer and closer,
and the goal is to get the
little piece of solder to melt.
What is it I'm looking for?
>> What you're going to see is once
you reach that magic temperature,
you're going to see that bar of
solder just like melt into the crack,
and once it melts,
that's when we want to back up.
We don't wanna keep on there too long
because we don't want
the solder overflowing,
and going to different parts of the brass.
And we also don't want it to bubble out.
>> And so, once it starts to puddle,
what are we-- are we talking like
half second, three seconds...
>> Probably around half second.
>> Okay so like it'll go
and just sort of that---
>> Yeah.
>> And do I stop the heat?
Or do I just back up so it's still...
>> I say back up.
>> Okay. Cool.
>> Yeah, just back up.
And we're using butane torches.
>> Butane.
[Music]
>> Brass is a bit more...
>> That's our--
Our flux starts bubbling up.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Pretty easily.
>> Flux is gonna go all white and crusty,
and then when you move in a little closer,
and we're going to see kind of bubble,
and eventually it's gonna go clear,
and when it goes kind
of dark then clear...
>> Oh, and the whole ring
just changed colors.
>> This is all oxidizing.
[Music]
>> Our solder has moved.
Is that a problem?
>> No, it's fine.
>> Okay.
>> Move a little closer,
and I'm making sure that we're
heating up this whole top surface.
>> Okay.
>> Cause brass is conductive.
[Music]
Alright now, you're going
to watch that melt in a second.
And brass is forgiving.
There we go.
Let's go back and forth one more time,
and have that flow tiny bit more.
>> Just puddle a little more than it did.
>> Exactly.
>> I was--I was too quick.
>> And that's it.
Great!
Cool.
So now what we have here,
is we have our brass then
we have our silver solder
that covered that whole crack.
So now, I'm gonna have you
grab that and quench it in the water.
>> Quenching.
[Music]
And once it's been underwater
for even a second,
It's fine to [inaudible]
>> It's thin enough that
it's just cooled off that quickly.
>> Okay, now we're gonna
see if our bezel fits our stone.
That should fit snug.
>> Right now, you'll notice
that the brass is all black.
>> Very discolored.
>> Very discolored and that's gonna
be that way until the very very end.
>> That's when we polish it.
>> We actually we'll
put it in acid for a while,
and that will help kind of soften it
and clean up a little bit,
and then we'll polish it.
Now that we have our stone in our bezel,
the next step is in to getting the sheet.
And the sheet we cut from just
a 26 gauge piece of brass sheet,
and we're going to measure it out,
and just cut a little more than enough
so we have something that
we can attach the bezel to.
and this will be the backing
that goes against your finger.
[Music]
One thing you're going to notice about
this sheet is it's kind of crazy looking.
>> It's a little warped.
>> It's really warped.
>> So we are--
>> I assume we want it flat.
>> Exactly.
So we need little anvil
and  our rawhide hammer.
We like using a rawhide hammer
when we work with metal
because it does not do any real dents.
[Music]
>> Is that flat enough?
>> Yeah.
That's perfect!
>> All right.
>> Probably spent twice
as long on that as I needed to.
>> Okay. so now we're going to be
soldering the bezel onto the sheet.
So that means that on this solder, we're
going to go ahead and use medium,
and medium melts a little bit lower...
>> Because this way,
we won't melt the first solder joint
but it will still bond to the brass,
so we don't lose what we've already done.
>> So go ahead and just
>> So we just grab pieces
>> line the inside.
>> and sort of line the inside.
>> That's right.
The important part about this solder
is that if you think about
these two pieces of metal,
you have the brass here
and you have a sheet here,
The brass bezel is going to get
hotter a lot faster than a sheet.
It's less dense.
There's less metal there.
So that means that what
you don't want to have happen
is for the bezel to get hot,
and then have all the solder
stick to the bezel
but have the sheet still cool
and have it never stick to the sheet.
Okay, let's aim down and go in circles.
So we're going to see--
We're gonna see the flux bubble,
which is totally normal,
and I'll come in here,
and kind of push those
solder bits close to the edge.
Right now, we're pretty hot.
So we're gonna focus on
getting the sheet hot.
So I want you to aim right in the center,
and then I want you to go
circles around the outside.
[Music]
Perfect.
Now, what we're looking for now
is if there's any light gaps.
So it looks like over here,
that's haven't quite melted.
So kind of go up and down on this end,
and big circles again.
Solder goes where it's hottest.
So what we're doing is
we're heating the inside,
and then going to the
outside and sucking it out,
and you are good.
So put the flame down.
[Music]
So now we have this piece of brass.
The bezel is soldered down to the sheet.
and an important part about this step
is we actually do not want
to shove our stone in there.
It's tempting but it will get stuck.
So we can kind of place it in there,
get an idea of how it's going to look,
we don't have to shove it into the--
into the actual bezel until the very end,
after it's all polished.
So  what we always do is
we're going to use scissors
just to cut as close as we can to the bezel
and then we're going to use
an actual lapidary machine grinder
to get right up against the edges.
[Music]
>> Definitely got some of
the brass color showing up
now that we've been grinding away
the oxidized layer on the outside.
>> That looks great.
So we have these nice curved
edges all the way around the outside.
My fingernail can't catch
any of these edges,
and we're not worried
about color quite yet.
Right now you'll see
it is brassy on the bottom half
because we just grinded that
and it's all right on the top half
but on the next solder
it's gonna be all red again.
So this is exactly what you want to see,
>> Sweet.
Now comes time to do the ring band.
So the ring band is going to be the
part that goes around your finger.
That's actually gonna hold
the stone in place.
So we are going to be
sizing this one to a 5.
>> Size 5 and that would
be Grant's left pinky finger.
>> That's right.
>> I believe.
>> So the way we get the
right size is we use a ring mandrel.
It has different numbers on here
gauging what size it is.
So we're aiming for that size 5 right there.
So begin wrapping your silver
band around the ring mandrel,
and trying to get to that size 5.
Once you kind of have the rough shape,
go ahead and just cut it.
Cut it like right here.
>> We still have a little more
material on there than I need, huh?
>> Yeah. So now what we do,
is actually slide it down
on the ring mandrel,
and use this rawhide hammer
just to make it into a circle.
We don't really worry about size as much.
[Music]
Now, we have the
ring band to the correct size,
and what we want to see is a really
good connection between the ring band
and this-- and the brass sheet.
So we're actually going to grind
a flat spot across top of this
so it lays flat.
So, that's perfect!
Now it's flat and it's
going to lay right on there.
Like I said earlier, the more connection,
the better for a solder.
So we're going to flux this up, as always,
and then we're actually use a third arm
to hold that in place right there.
>> Easy solder this time?
>> Yes!
The goal with this solder
is to get it just hot enough
for the easy solder to melt,
and make that connection strong.
But we do not want to get too hot
because if we get it too hot...
>> We'll lose the other two bonds.
>> Exactly.
So with this solder what we're focusing on
again is getting that sheet nice and hot.
We do want the band to be hot as well.
So it has something that the solder will
have something to connect to.
A little closer...
[Music]
And if you watch closely,
you're gonna see that brass turn all black.
[Music]
That's great! Perfect!
>> All right.
>> All right, go ahead and quench it.
[Music]
That looks like a ring.
>> Okay.
So we always check those solders,
make sure that they're nice and secure.
I kind of wiggle it a little bit
and these aren't going anywhere.
So now comes the next step,
and we're going to drop
this at Crock-Pot full of acid.
>> We've got our slow cooker full
of acid and then we just drop the ring in.
How long do we leave it in there?
>> We leave it in for like 5-10 minutes,
and then once it's gonna go,
it's gonna go in looking pretty black,
but it comes out brass
its gonna look kind of light red.
[Music]
Okay, so we pulled it out of a Crock-Pot,
and now you're going to notice
that there's a bit of a red hue
across all of the brass.
>> Yeah, it looks more
like Copper at this point.
>> Exactly.
So now we're going to do is we're
going to grind away all of that red,
and underneath that,
you're going to see a lot
of really pretty brass color.
So we're gonna use the
lapidary machine one more time,
and we're going to use some
of the softer grinding wheels,
they're more like sandpaper.
Now ground down pretty much all
of the red surfaces that I can get to,
and it's time to move on
to the polishing wheel.
This is a very very fine grit
stuff that sticks to our wheel,
and then it polishes the brass
just by being very slightly abrasive.
[Music]
Our ring is all cleaned, polished
and cut and ready to go,
and for the most part,
the bezel should do its job
and hold the stone in.
All right, the stone is set.
This was a pretty tight fit.
And now do we want to bend the bezel
in over it just a little bit to hold it better.
>> So, this is call it burnishing tool,
and what we use this
for is to bend that brass
over the top of the stone like that
all the way around.
Put your whole strength into it.
We want to bend that brass
as closely to the stone as possible.
>> Awesome.
Now some of my fingernails
may have some black metal polish
under them at the moment.
But there you go, the five rings,
and this are not size for my hands.
I can't quite get them on all of the fingers.
I've just got them set up like this.
But they're looking pretty nice.
We've got some great colors
and some very shiny brass.
We've got five rings
and a bracelet made.
That I think makes us
as powerful as Thanos.
Powerful as Thanos.
[Music]
Thanks again to Matt
here at the Gem Studio.
Matt, where can people
find out more about this place?
So you have to find us at
the.gemstudio on Instagram,
or the GemStudio.com.
Guys, that's not all.
We've got more for you to see.
that box up at the top will transport
you directly to our last video,
and you should go check that out.
The box in the bottom will show you what
YouTube thinks you should be watching next.
If you hit this bomb in the middle,
you'll be subscribed to our channel.
So you never miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see in the next one.
Talk to you then.